okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the gravitational potential energy
store also known as the GPE store so
whenever an object is at any height
above the Earth's surface it will have
energy in its gravitational potential
and energy store or its GPE store so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna look
at what that actually means so let's
imagine here this is the ground right
here and we have three rocks and these
three rocks are at different heights so
which one would have the most energy in
the GPE store well the answer is the
answer is this one right here so the
higher an object is away from the
surface of the earth the more energy it
will have in the GPE store so we can
think about this because when we let
this each of them go the energy will be
converted from the GPE store into the
kinetic energy store and which one will
there be most kinetic energy released
well from the highest up one so the
higher and the object is the greater the
amount of energy in the GPE store so
let's have a look at a different example
so this time we've got rocks again but
this time they're all where they're
meant to be at the same height now which
one is going to have more energy in the
GPE store well the answer is this one
because it has the greatest mass so the
greater the mass the greater the amount
of energy in the GPE store again because
if I was to let each of these go this
one would have the greatest amount of
kinetic energy as it falls because
kinetic energy depends on mass as well
so those are two parts of the GPE
equation that we need to know we know
that it relies on height so the higher
it is the more DP you'll have and mass
but there's something else as well that
we'll see right now so the change in G
PE equals the mass times G which we'll
talk about in a second
time's by the change in height so this
here this little triangle
it's the symbol means Delta and it just
means change in so this means the change
in gravitational potential energy so M
stands for mass which is measured in
kilograms now the G this here stands for
gravitational field strength
gravitational field strength now
gravitational field strength is always
measured in Newtons per kilogram now
what this means is just the strength of
the gravitational pull acting upon the
object if for example we went to the
moon from the earth the moon has a
weaker gravitational field strength than
the earth on earth the gravitational
field strength is 10 Newton's per
kilogram we need to know this number
right here than earth it's always 10 but
if we went with somewhere else for
example the moon the gravitational field
strength would be less so therefore an
object's at the same height with the
same mass will have a different amount
of GPA depending on whether it's on the
earth or on the moon now a Delta H just
means a change in height which is
measured in meters so let's just have a
quick look and use this as an example
here so let's imagine we have this
Boulder here which is 5 meters above the
surface of of the earth here of the
ground and let's say it has a mass of a
hundred kilograms now let's imagine this
is on earth as well so to find the
change in GPA all we need to do is do
the mass which is 100 hundred kilograms
multiplied by the gravitational field
strength now remember whenever we're on
earth we always know our GPA is going to
be 10 and finally
multiplied by the change in height which
is five so that answer gives me my
change in GPA which is 5,000 and
remember whenever we have energy no
matter what kind of energy is bit
kinetic energy gravitational potential
energy whatever type of energy it is
always measured in joules so that is
basically how gravitation potential
energy works it relies on three things
Mass gravitational field strength and
the change in height thank you